on va maintenant prendre la direction de
vinnytsia c'est dans le centre de
l'ukraine où se trouve notre envoyé
spécial tarek khaïri vous êtes à vigny
tsia parce que c'est la ville qui abrite
le quartier général de l'armée de l'air
ukrainienne vous avez pu vous entretenir
avec les officiers de l'armée
ukrainienne expliquez-nous comment ils
font face à l'invasion russe de
l'ukraine
tout simplement il faut à face avec
beaucoup de difficultés il essaie
justement de contenir l'avancée russe
parce que cette question de la
supériorité aérienne et de la maîtrise
du ciel a depuis le début de ce conflit
était une question cruciale est majeur
les premières frappes où l'une des
principales les premières cibles de la
part de l'armée russe c'était les
installations et la capacité aérienne
ukrainienne qu'elle soit défensives ou
offensives
on connaît cette fameuse expression bien
connue dans le milieu de la stratégie
militaire qui dit qu'ils maîtrisent le
ciel gagner la guerre on peut dire que
jusqu'à présent c'est la russie qui
maîtrise le ciel en partie et je dirais
en partie puisque l'ukraine est ici plus
ou moins à contenir certaines des
attaques russes selon un porte parole de
l'armée de l'air avec lequel nous nous
sommes entretenu la veille crânienne a
réussi jusqu'à présent à battre à plus
de 55 avions de chasse et plus de 80
hélicoptères russes mais il avoue
néanmoins que c'est la supériorité de la
mère russe en terme justement de
capacité est bien présente d'où ces
appels
à l'égard de la communauté
internationale ou plus précisément à
l'égard des alliés des pays alliés de
doter la mairie crânienne d'armes qui
pourrait contrebalancer le pouvoir des
armes russes à titre d'exemple ici même
l'aéroport de vinnytsia été la cible de
huit missiles la rue sylvia quelques
jours des missiles qui ont complètement
détruit les repas des missiles de type h
sans freins capable de traverser plus de
5000 km aujourd'hui on considérer ici
que la balle est dans le camp des
occidentaux
je vous propose à cet égard à d'écouter
un extrait de l'entretien que nous a
accordé le porte parole de l'armée de
l'air au kenya
l'ukraine reçoit différentes armes cela
a été rendu public des armes antichars
no2 grande bretagne des missiles jav
l'un des états unis et les armes
allemandes aussi
nous parlons ici d'armes antichars et
antiaériens
qui peuvent atteindre 4 kilomètres et
demi de hauteur et 6 km de portée
maintenant les dossiers avec nos
partenaires des armements des avions des
systèmes antiaériens beaucoup plus
puissant nous voulons montrer que si
nous ne sommes pas livré l'ukraine sera
détruite sens unique rennes forte il n'y
aura pas d' europe forte
en plus de cet appel justement de la
part des responsables ukrainiens se pose
également la question de la zone
d'exclusion
aérienne
une demande qui revient de manière
incessante de la part des autorités
ukrainiennes
merci beaucoup tarek à kayes en direct
de vinnytsia